i once saw a high school teacher lead a
simple powerful exercise to teach his
class about privilege and social
mobility he started by giving each
student a scrap piece of paper and asked
them to crumple it up
then he moved the recycling bin to the
front of the room
he said the game is simple you all
represent the country's population and
everyone in the country has a chance to
become wealthy and move into the upper
class to move into the upper class all
you must do is throw your wadded up
paper into the bin while sitting in your
seat the students in the back of the
room immediately piped up saying this is
unfair
they could see the rows of students in
front of them had a much better chance
everyone took their shots and as
expected most of the students in the
front made it but not all and only a few
students in the back of the room made it
he concluded by saying the closer you
were to the recycling bin the better
your odds
this is what privilege looks like did
you notice how the only ones who
complained about fairness were in the
back of the room by contrast people in
the front of the room were less likely
to be aware of the privilege they were
born into all they can see is 10 feet
between them and their goal
your job as students who are receiving
an education is to be aware of your
privilege and use this particular
privilege called education to do your
best to achieve great things all the
while advocating for those in the rows
behind you